Alright Michael, so there's lots of definitions
of game theory that we could use.
One that I like in particular is
that game theory is the mathematics of conflict.
>> Hm, [CROSSTALK] that's interesting.
>> I think it's kind of interesting. Or generally it's the
mathematics of conflicts of interest when trying to make optimal choices.
>> because I feel like a lot
of people have their own conflicts with mathematics.
>> I think everyone but mathematicians have
their conflicts with mathematics. I think that's fair.
>> I see.
>> But do you see if you, can you see
how worrying about the mathematical conflict might be a sort of
natural next thing to think about after you've learned a lot
about reinforcement learning? I guess then well the next bullet kind
of, kind of suggests a trend. So, so we've been talking about
decision making and it's almost always in the context of a
single agent that lives in a world and it's trying to maximize
reward. But that's kind of a lonely way to think about
things, so what if there's other agents in the world with you?
>> Right and of course evidence suggests that there are in
fact other agents in the world with you. And what we've been
doing with reinforcement learning which, you know, has worked out very well
for us, is we've been mostly pretending that those other agents are
just a part of the environment. Somehow all the stuff that
the other agents do is hidden inside of the transition model. But
truthfully it probably makes sense if you want to make optimal decisions
to try to take into account explicitly the desires and the goals
of all the other agents in the world with you. Does that seem fair?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So that's what game theory helps us to do
and then at the very end I think we'll, we'll be
able to tie what we're going to learn Directly back into the
reinforcement learning that we've done and even into the Bellman equation.
>> Oh, okay, nice.
>> Yeah, so that is going to work out pretty well but,
but we have to get there first and there's a lot
of stuff that we have to do to get there. But
right now what I want you to think about is this notion
that, we're going to move from reinforcement learning world of single
agents to a game theory world of multiple agents and tie
it all back back together. It's a sort of general
note that I think that, that's worthwhile is that, game theory
sort of comes out of economics. And then in fact,
if you think about multiple agents there being millions and millions
of multiple agents, in some sense that's economics. Right? Economics is
kind of the math, and the science, and the art of
thinking about what happens when there are, lots, and lots, and
lots, and lots of people with their own goals possibility conflicting, trying
to work together to accomplish something, right. And so what game
theory does, is it gives us mathematical tools to think about that.
>> I feel like I feel like other fields
would care about some of these things too, like sociology.
>> Right.
>> And what about, I could kind
of imagine biology caring about these things, too.
>> Even biology, I like the idea of
biology. Biology. Why would biology care about this?
>> Well, I guess the way you described it
in terms of lots of individual agents that are interacting.
Like, you know, creatures that live and reproduce. I
feel like they, they have some of those same issues.
>> Sure. So certainly biology at at the level of entities, at the level of
mammals or level of insects, you might be able to think about it that way.
But perhaps even at the level of genes and at the level of
cells. Little virii and, and bacteria. You
could possibly think about it that way.
>> because they're in conflict too, I guess.
>> Yeah. Now there's probably this notion of
intention. It's not entirely clear what that means here
and I think implicit in the notion of
what we're doing here is this notion of intention
and explicit goals as opposed to ones that
are kind of built into your genes, but I think
that's a perfectly reasonable way of thinking about
it. I think the, the lesson from this discussion
though is that. What game theory sort of captures for us or
what would like for it to capture for us, is ways of thinking
about what happens when you're not the only thing with intention in
the world and how do you incorporate other goals from other people who
might not have your best interest at heart or might have your
best interest at heart. How do you make that work? And so if
you think about that problem then I think it makes sense that it's
been increasingly a part of AI over the years, and in some ways
machine learning has started to think of it
as being a mainstream part of what we do.
>> Cool.
>> Hence, why it's worth talking about today. Okay. Sound good.
>> Gotcha.
>> Okay. Let's, let's try to make this
concrete with a very simple sort of example.